but blm believes that it can subvert our
justice system
all around the country notably in the
case of
the george floyd trial the derek chauvin
trial into the the death of george floyd
there was a juror we were told the
jurors are not being influenced at all
by you know the most important news
story in the country that led to the
burning of multiple cities no they
weren't influenced at all
they don't have any opinions on this
very contentious topic
they're totally objective and
disinterested right
except there's a photo that just came
out of one of the jurors wearing a blm
shirt that says get your knee off our
necks so it's referring directly
to the derek chovin incident with george
floyd
the photo was posted in august by this
juror's
uncle it was taken in washington dc
at an event commemorating martin luther
king
in many ways quite ironic you got to
throw this trial out
it's ridiculous derek chovin should not
spend one more second
in prison it
at so many stages of this process
there have been there has been a lot of
evidence to say
this is not fair this is not going to be
justice maxine waters threatening to
start riots if they don't get the
ridiculous
charges that they wanted the president
of the united states putting his thumb
on the scales
and now we find out that the jury was
rigged
that the juror who went in and said i
have no dog in this fight i don't have
any opinions i'm totally impartial
turns that he's a member of blm throw it
out
throw out the trial but michael what if
derek chovan did something wrong
what if he did isn't isn't the whole
argument for
among the criminal justice reformers
that it would be better to let 10 guilty
men go free than to have one innocent
man
in prison that we need to we need to err
on the side of leniency well i'm not
even saying air on the side of leniency
i'm just saying that people are entitled
to due process and if the due process is
not being recognized
then then you cannot keep the guy in
prison
you're probably not going to hear about
that that juror unless you're listening
to this show
maybe if you're reading a handful of
conservative outlets maybe you'll hear
about it but maybe you won't
why not because the systems of
justice and communication in this
country more importantly communication
probably
are rigged for the libs did you see
there was a story yesterday out
that a girl who cheated at a homecoming
queen election
is going to face jail time but those two
girls
who carjacked that poor pakistani guy
and killed him the other day
they're never going to see the inside of
a jail cell you remember that story we
covered it on this show too
why because the systems of
justice and the dominant narrative in
this country
are rigged in the liberal direction
and i'm not just talking about cnn we'll
get to cnn later
i'm not just talking about the
mainstream media i'm talking about the
new media too i'm talking about
the internet i'm talking about the whole
thing hey hold on a second
first i've just got to celebrate that we
haven't been taken off youtube
i thought i was sure that that show was
gonna i didn't think they were gonna
like that one but
if you're hearing this and seeing this
then the show is is not off youtube yet
ring the bell like subscribe that is how
you will at least have a better chance
of getting notifications when we get
more videos out
i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you